hi the polls tell us that Americans do
not want the Supreme Court overturn its
1973 roe v wade ruling on abortion in a
Gallup question from July 64% did not
want the decision overturned new polls
from Fox News and the Kaiser Family
Foundation produced similar results that
said most Americans believe that
abortion should be legal only under
certain circumstances and they are
willing to put considerable restrictions
on the procedure in gálvez polling on
the issue for example around 60 percent
say it should be possible for a woman to
obtain a legal abortion in the first
three months of a pregnancy that dropped
sharply to around 30 percent when people
are asked about abortions in the second
trimester and only 10% when pollsters
ask about the third trimester in gallops
latest poll for May this year 48% of
people said that they considered
themselves to be pro-life and an
identical 48 percent said that they were
pro-choice the split reflects Americans
beliefs in the sanctity of life
and the importance of individual choice
do you think Rovio age should be
overturned let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI